so do you remember that that fight in
the brown Steelers game miles Garrett
versus Mason Rudolph Garrett tears
Rudolph's helmet off and smacks him with
it
well let's let's relive the moment just
really briefly so we can talk about it
watch this
now he tackled Rudolph Rudolph didn't
like the way that he was tackled oh my
goodness
yes memories the memories well Garrett
got suspended indefinitely at least at
least for the year if not longer and
that was a week ago that had happened
the week goes by and the most
frustrating thing about what happens
next is that it's just so utterly
predictable just you-you-you knew it was
happening you knew it was gonna happen
we all saw it coming so Garrett now
miles Garrett the aggressor in the
situation the guy that took toward the
helmet off and hit somebody else with it
he now in an effort to excuse his
actions and to deflect blame and to get
a suspension overturned or at least
minimized he now says that Mason Rudolph
used a racial slur towards him of course
right that's just of course nobody
mentioned anything about a racial slur
before but now the claim comes out that
oh by the way a week later but yeah he
said racial slur just so you know first
of all I think that as people have been
talking about this whether or not it's
true or whatever
this hasn't been stipulated enough but
even if it was true okay
even if Mason Rudolph really did call
Miles Garrett a racial slur that would
not in any way justify ripping his
helmet off and beating him in the head
with it I would hope we could all agree
with that but apparently we can't
because people are talking about this
issue as if the only thing that matters
is whether or not it's true that either
Mason Rudolph said that when really even
if he said it that doesn't do much to
negate the fact that Miles Garrett
ripped a guy's head off at him and had
with it and could have caused brain
damage or worse so it's kind of like
that maybe you saw that video of it was
when viral a few weeks ago of a woman
older woman getting body slammed in the
parking lot of a Popeyes by a Popeyes
employee and the claim that I saw online
is that the woman used a racial slur
towards that guy there was a guy body
slamming her I have no idea if that's
true or not I never looked into
that story doesn't really matter my
point is people were sharing the video
as number one assuming that she used the
racial slur and then number two assuming
that it therefore justifies in older an
old woman being body slammed on the
pavement but even if she it's bad if she
used the racial slur that doesn't mean
you can body slam her and potentially
kill her yeah I mean just you can't we
agree with that that there is no there
is no no word or insult or anything that
could be said that would justify
physical assault especially to the point
of potentially killing somebody you'd
hope we could agree with that but
apparently we can second thing though
there is there is no evidence that
Rudolph said any such thing the the NFL
looked into it they found no evidence
Miles Garrett's own teammates said they
never heard it or heard about it until
just now
Rudolph's teammates Rudolph's teammates
never heard it or heard about it so
there's a bunch of people around there
you know while this play is going on and
you've got 22 guys on the field
none of them heard it and it's not just
that they didn't hear the slur it's that
Garrett's own teammates when they pulled
Garrett off brought him to the sidelines
later in the locker room he apparently
never mentioned this to anybody he never
said hey that deck that guy called me
XYZ you'd think he would have been one
of the first things he said especially
when you're you know they're in the
middle of fighting and he's enraged and
you pull him off the guy wouldn't he's
saying things wouldn't he be saying
something like he called me this in fact
Garrett himself was interviewed by the
media immediately after it happened and
he didn't say anything about this he had
he's talking to cameras news cameras
this was after the fact perfect
opportunity for him to do some damage
control and and and say well this is
what he said to me didn't say that so
nobody heard it nobody heard Garrett
mention it
Garrett himself didn't mention it and
all the cameras and mics all over the
field apparently didn't pick it up
plus there's been no indication that I'm
aware of that Rudolph has a history of
using that word he's rude lots been
playing football for years has a lot of
black teammates he's been presumably
tackled by black players many times
throughout his football life we can
assume and as far as we know he's never
used the racial slur before so why would
he all of a sudden start using it now
all of these factors just make it
impossible to believe or at least very
hard to believe so it seems like we've
got a jussie Smollett in cleats here
situation and I'll tell you this if
Garrett lied about this and slandered
the man right after trying to cross
caused brain damage so first he rips his
helmet off and beats him with it and
then later week later lies about it
tries to permanently damage his
reputation then he needs to be sued not
just for physical assault but also for
slander and he also needs to be
suspended from the league for another
year so put tack another year on to
however long this suspension was
supposed to be because that's actually
worse than the original physical assault
when you think about the long-term
damage to someone's career reputation
you could do by making something like
that up all right before we go on a
quick word from honey you know giving
holiday gifts is great overspending on
all those gifts is definitely not so
great and that's the hard part about the
holidays is all the money that you're
spending so why spend more than you have
to find the lowest price you possibly
can and that's very easy if you have
honey honey is a free browser extension
that automatically finds the best promo
codes whenever you shop online listen
I'm not usually one to get my my holiday
shopping done early you know I'm usually
waiting until Christmas Eve that kind of
guy but it's a lot easier with honey
and I can save a lot of money so it
takes the it takes the anxiety out of it
so it's easier for me to do it early so
I've used and I've basically done my
holiday shop I can save the ton of money
and now I can cruise to the holidays
carefree
shopping for the holidays without honey
I think is just well it's reckless why
would you do it
honey's found over it's over ten million
members over a billion dollars in
savings honey supports over twenty
thousand stores online and has over a
hundred thousand five-star review
reviews on the google chrome store so
you know that people like it if you're
buying holiday gifts this season then
you need honey if you're not you
probably know someone who is buying
gifts and so you could at least tell
them about about honey honey can help
make sure that you're getting the best
price for whatever you're buying it's
free to use and it installs in just two
clicks so it's very easy get honey for
free at join honey calm slash Walsh
that's join honey dot-com slash Walsh
okay
very briefly Tesla interviewed this or
unveiled I should say Tesla unveiled
this new thing called the cyber truck
this was their new truck and the cyber
truck is supposed to have along with
various other features it's supposed to
have unbreakable armored glass for some
reason and but they tested the the
armored glass at the unveiling and it
didn't go so well watch this okay but
really the bigger issue here is that
this is the ugliest damn truck I've ever
seen in my life it out it looks like
what my three-year-old would come up
with if you asked him to draw a truck
that's that's what he would draw it
looks like an early prototype of the of
the Batmobile in the dark night was the
dark night the was it the baton the
tumbler Batmobile thing looks like that
and I don't mean that as a compliment
and I'm really yeah I'm watching this
and seeing the cyber truck because when
you hear cyber truck you're thinking of
something futuristic something really
cool and you see it and you're
disappointed and I'm I'm just
disappointed in general because it's the
year 2019 and guys like Elon Musk are
supposed to be inventing hovercrafts and
like cars that shoot laser beams and
stuff
that's that's what we're supposed to
have time machines in our garages and
time machines are supposed to be
everyday items at this point in the year
2019 and instead this is what we get
this is the vehicle of the future this
this something that looks like it was
pasted together from refrigerator boxes
and then painted silver this is our
future it really is it really is
discipline I mean if you had to back in
the 70s and 80s when they were thinking
about the year 2020 they were thinking
hoverboards hovercrafts flying vehicles
everywhere
everyone has a robot slave in their home
that's what they're thinking
aliens have long since visited were
cruising across the galaxy
and nope nothing it's just it's just
this alright um Ann Coulter spoke at
Berkeley or a few nights ago and the
students reacted exactly as you would
think they would mobs and protests and
everything but here's one video of a
young woman trying to walk to the talk
she's trying to get to the speech where
n Coulter is talking and she meets a mob
and the mob steals her ticket screams in
her face harasses her and won't let her
pass watch
every time I see these videos it just
becomes it becomes clear to me that the
rule of law is is apparently dead the
law doesn't matter these people are
allowed to do this every week we see
this stuff why is it every week we get
another video of of leftist rage mobs
assaulting and harassing people shut it
whatever they whether they're shutting
down traffic or they're not letting
people pass or whatever the vandalizing
and yet no police arrest them why you
lose like when's the last time you saw a
video like this and then you saw the
police show up and arrest a bunch of
people and throw them in the paddy wagon
when's the last thing it never happens
they're just allowed to do what they
want there should be 50 people arrested
at every one of these events the cops
should be there in force and the minute
you see someone break the law like for
instance stealing their ticket from them
that's that's theft okay
haul them away throw put them in jail
they committed a crime
what do you let's let's let's take
control again have some rule of law but
apparently now I I didn't get the memo
but apparently if you if you get
together with a big enough group of
people the law doesn't matter you can do
whatever you want
so if you
get together it doesn't need to be that
big of a group I mean you get together
with ten people and just block the
traffic in DC and let's just let you -
it's it's a couple weeks ago probably
get a handful of people sitting in the
middle of the road to traffic in
Washington DC and that's it you can just
do it I guess no one's gonna stop you
it's crazy there should be you could put
a stop to this stuff just do mass
arrests because the moment you see this
and they're harassing people not living
in the past this is not free speech this
is not a protest okay this is a crime
happening these people are part of a mob
not a protest and so just start
arresting everybody and you could put a
stop to this stuff pretty quickly hey by
the way if you haven't been listening to
Andrew clave ins fantasy podcast another
Kingdom then you got to go to daily wire
comm and subscribe right now to catch up
because on Monday November 25th at 7
p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific Andrew and
Michael Knowles we sitting - get down
together to discuss the final season and
also them to take subscriber questions
live from the fans the live event would
be free for everyone to watch on
Facebook and YouTube but only
subscribers will be able to ask
questions at daily wire.com Plus
subscribers exclusively can watch the
entirety of the season or you can listen
free of the newest season on Apple
podcast go check it out don't miss
another Kingdom live discussion
happening Monday at 7 p.m. Eastern 4
p.m. Pacific I want to mention this -
we've been talking about the issue with
the locker rooms of the school in
Illinois the school board voting to
allow boys into the girls locker room
thereby putting girls in danger
obliterating their privacy well the
video I've played and talked about
plenty the video of the biological male
celebrating the decision gloating and
then the girl crying expressing her
worries about now the fact that she's
not gonna privacy when she gets changed
that video was was shared by someone on
Twitter someone who's on the side of the
boy okay someone who thinks that the boy
has a right to the women's locker room
and this person's tweet about the video
the only reason I'm mentioning it there
is
noticed it is there tweet about the
video in support of the boy got over a
hundred thousand likes 100 thousand okay
over a hundred thousand people saw this
and agreed with him that yeah I'm on the
boys side and I just here's what he says
about the video and and specifically
about the girl crying about losing her
privacy rights
he says when we when we desegregated
bathrooms
some white girls also held back tears
because a black woman might see them
naked too and that's it that's a zarkan
so what we have here is someone and
again over a hundred thousand people
like this argent we have someone
accusing a young girl of bigotry because
she doesn't want to be naked around boys
think about that think about how creepy
and perverse that is think about what a
creepy weird person you have to be to
see it like that
to actually get angry at a young girl a
minor a child because she doesn't want
to be naked around a boy so it's it's
it's not even just that you're you you
think you're trying to it's not even
just that you support this but you're
actually mad at her for not wanting to
be naked around a boy think about that
and the argument he makes and this is a
popular argument this is something that
this is an argument that that the LGBTQ
camp
they're always doing this comparing
themselves to to the plight of
segregated black Americans or or even
you know going back to slavery times and
trying to draw these comparisons and
it's so just disrespectful and degrading
and it's also idiotic because the point
here is that black people have a right
to the same accommodations as white
people okay
that's the whole point with civil rights
and desegregation but so yes we all
agree with that that doesn't mean that
boys have a right to access the same
locker rooms as girls you see it it's
not hard to understand there's a
distinction there so it is very possible
to argue that black people have a right
to the same accommodations as white
people without also arguing that
biological boys have a right to get
naked in front of girls it in fact the
two issues have nothing to do with one
another at all it's they're not they're
not remotely similar another way of
putting it is you can disagree with
racial segregation while still agreeing
with other forms of segregation that
have nothing to do with race whatsoever
and so segregating locker rooms and
separating boys and girls that's
segregation yes got nothing to do with
race this form of segregation over here
perfectly acceptable and good and the
right thing to do
by the way I started going back and
forth with this guy started arguing with
him and finally he pulls out a study and
you know how I love it when people try
to win arguments by pulling out studies
oh yeah well I've got a study that says
this and I just want to say this is a
great example of how people and this is
sort of a hobby horse of mine now is is
combating the fallacious use of studies
which i think is an epidemic now online
that people they just to try to win an
argument at Google they try to find a
headline about a study that proves their
point don't even read the study and then
they just say see here's a study I win
as if as if as if it proves anything as
if it at all proves your point because
you were able to google and cherry-pick
and find a headline about a study that
seems to sort of support means nothing
okay
so he he sends me a screenshot a
screenshot not a link okay that's a red
flag big red flag here sends me a
screenshot of a headline from NBC News
and the headline is trans teens face
higher sexual assault risk when schools
restrict bathrooms study finds more than
one in four of transgender and
non-binary students have surveyed
reported being sexually assaulted in the
previous 12 months okay now the obvious
insinuation here and the reason why this
guy was I think it's a guy the reason
why this person was presenting this to
me is because the implication is that
making a quote trans girl that is a
biological girl identified a biological
boy who identifies as a girl making that
that individual use the boys facilities
with his other biological counterparts
that somehow puts him at risk for sexual
assault and so what you're meant to take
from this headline what this guy on
Twitter and also what NBC News wants you
to take from the headline is that
apparently there's an epidemic of trans
people of quote trans girls again
biological I'm only using this
terminology just for the sake of
argument to talk
the study there's a there's a well you
what they want us to take from this is
that there's an epidemic of
quote-unquote trans girls getting
sexually assaulted in the boys rooms
which is why we need to put them into
the girls rooms that's what we're meant
to take from this one in four Wow
now here's the thing even if that were
true it still would not justify putting
boys into the girls room because even if
you could prove that we have some real
concern about the safety of these
individuals in the boys room that
doesn't mean we sit we sacrifice the
safety and security of the girls doesn't
mean we just we put them all up on the
altar for sacrifice no that would be an
argument for giving them a separate
facility and saying okay now you can go
use this other bathroom over here and
you could have privacy you could be by
yourself
in fact the school that we're talking
about in in Illinois that's what they
were doing they were giving the trans
students a separate privacy area no risk
of sexual assault there you're the only
one in it in it right so that would be
an argument for that but that's not the
argument that the left is making they're
saying they don't know don't give them
their own private area put them in with
the girls so it's actually got nothing
to do with sexual assault at all but of
course you know and this is what you
when you when you see a headline like
this your your BS detector has to be
going haywire you think of what one in
4ch what you're telling me one in four
of trans students and immense in the
boys bathroom and locker we're getting
sexually assaulted what that sounds
crazy there's no way that's true and so
then I went and googled it clicked on it
and sure enough it is crazy it's not
true it even says in the second
paragraph of the article that this
person linked well they didn't link to
it just gave me that the screenshot it
says in the second paragraph the study's
author admits that there isn't
necessarily any causal relationship
between the bathroom policies and the
sexual assault of trans students
so they didn't establish any causal
relationship at all and they're not
actually talking about sexual assaults
in bathrooms what the study is saying is
they're they're taking a look at sexual
assault in general and they're using
information compiled by among others the
Human Rights Campaign which is a far far
far radical left organization so you've
got all kinds of problems with the
methodology that they're that this is
this is far from objective research this
this is this is completely biased and
they are relying on information from
organizations that have an obvious
ideological stake in the matter but
putting even that aside which you can't
really do but we'll put it aside anyway
what they're saying is they're looking
for instance so for example to get to
this one-in-four statistic you could
have a transgender student who for
example was abused at home and they're
they're lumping that in with the
one-in-four okay
taking abuse and assaults that happen
far outside of any bathroom and they're
somehow trying to link it to the
bathroom it's just completely arbitrary
and absurd obviously if a trans student
is abused at home terrible thing it's
got nothing to do with bathroom policies
at school clearly so what happened with
this study clearly what happened with
the study is what the study's authors
wanted to discover what they were
looking for they wanted to find that
trans that these biological males who
identifies females are somehow at risk
in the male bathroom that's that's the
result they were trying to find they
didn't find it they didn't find what
they were looking for so instead they
they in fact what they found is there's
no correlation at all there's no issue
here these these students are not at
risk in the male bathroom that's what
they found but they tried to find a way
of presenting the information so that
there would still seem to be kind of a
link and then the media helps them out
by coming up with a headline like this
that is completely and totally
misleading and this really is how fake
news works so the headline here is
technically true so they can always
claim that then lie but it's also
obviously grossly misleading that's why
I always say with studies if someone
throws a study at you and it doesn't
mean
anything until you've read it and in
fact we should not be you know we should
not be presenting study you you
shouldn't be presenting a study as
evidence for your claim unless you have
read the study not read a headline about
it not read an article about it but you
need to have actually read the study
itself the entire thing if you haven't
done that then you have no business
quoting a study none and in fact to
quote the study that you have in red is
dishonest and it is a form of lying
because you know that you're trying to
support an argument and you're using
this and but you don't actually know if
it's a legitimate study or not and you
know that you don't know that but you're
using it anyway so that's dishonest and
it's lying and you know it's something a
lot of people do on both sides and I
think we need to get a hold of that okay
let's go to emails Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com this is from Trevor hey Matt I
wanted to ask you something that may
seem trivial at first but it's been on
my mind for a while but it's how can I
critically think better I asked this
question because I'm really into history
philosophy and theology but I find that
I hold most of my views because I just
happen to agree with someone but I
discussed my views with people they
compliment me on my knowledge or my
opinion on the subject but I can't help
but remember that I only hold my views
mainly because I've just heard other
people make the points the only thing
I've done is memorize ideas and agree or
disagree with them I'm not sure if I'm
being too hard on myself but I can't
help feeling a little bit like a fraud
how can I get better at coming up with
my own original takes on things and then
building my convictions off of them also
I study history at universities so it
would only help if I got better at
thinking critically I also I ask you
because out of all the conservative
speakers I have listened to you seem to
have the most nuanced takes I never hear
the typical right wing talking points
and I can't really predict what you're
going to say about a certain topic and
I'm always interested with your take and
rationale behind it not exactly trying
to flatter you
although take it how you want just
thought you are top-notch example of
thinking for yourself and then letting
those original thoughts shape your
beliefs we'd love to hear your advice
well Trevor see I have to disagree with
you number one I'm not a top notch
thinker I'm you know I'm I'm a little
mediocre let's be honest hit or miss
number two I don't think you need help
thinking critically because you're
obviously doing a great job of it this
email what you're describing here this
is critical thinking what you're doing
right now is critical thinking and this
is exactly the sort of self reflection
and self analysis that most people never
engage in so you are already way way way
ahead of the curve and people who lack
critical thinking skills which most
people do in my experience certainly
never have this thought process that
you're having right now so and I think
it's great I mean I think it's great
that you're the fact that you're saying
this about yourself and noticing this
about yourself is a really good sign
so what you're doing here is asking
really basic question a question that is
a starting point for all critical
thinking and a question that I'm that
again I'm betting most people in this
country and in across the world have
never asked themselves and the question
is this why do I believe the things that
I believe and what you've discovered is
the same truth that any one of us will
discover the first time we ask this
question to ourselves the first time we
sincerely and seriously asked this
question of ourselves well you find is
that you believe most of what you
believe because you have passively
inherited those beliefs from your
parents from your friends from the media
from people around you from the culture
etc so it's just been this sort of you
know you're like like a sponge just
soaking in things but not really
thinking much about them you don't have
necessarily good reasons for some of the
things that you believe you have talking
points which you've memorized but that's
not the same as having a reason and this
is the case for everyone before they've
really taken on the task of critical
thinking so you know don't feel bad
about you should feel proud of yourself
that you're that you're thinking about
this and engaging this process in the
first place so here's the good news
just because you wouldn't you've
inherited certain convictions just
because you don't really have
necessarily good reasons for thinking
some of the things you think it doesn't
necessarily mean that you're wrong about
those things
doesn't mean that all your beliefs are
wrong but it does
that they could be wrong right for all
you know so now you have to take those
beliefs sort of metaphorically pull them
out of your mind
place them on the table in front of you
and and inspect them do it do an honest
inspection and so here are just some
ideas on how you know how we can become
critical thinkers and I give this advice
not as an expert but as a as I guess a
striver
I suppose like you so I think the first
step when you notice that you believe
something but don't have great reasons
for believing it the first step is to do
what you've already done which is to
acknowledge and say okay you know I
might be wrong about this and and now
with that simple acknowledgement you're
setting yourself up for an objective
analysis of the question because you
can't objectively analyze anything if
you're not willing to admit that you
might be wrong so if on any subject
you've never said to yourself I might be
wrong about this then you've never
objectively considered it no matter what
it is whatever the conviction belief
whatever is if you've never at any point
considered the possibility that you
could be wrong then you've never looked
at it objectively which probably means
you have no good reason for thinking it
okay but so once you've done that now
you're ready for objective consideration
and and so that's good and now I think
it's a simple process of listening to
looking at reading giving a fair hearing
to all of the sides of the issue in
question whatever it is seek out the
very best arguments and the most
articulate defenders of the various
different views let them speak for
themselves don't seek out one side's
version of what the other side says
don't do that let that side speak for
itself and really challenge yourself
find the people because it's very easy
and we all do this sometimes make we
make ourselves feel better about our
convictions by only engaging with the
dumbest people on the other side of it
so that we feel even better
we can leave saying oh wow these people
have any arguments they're a bunch of
morons and depending on what it is I
mean there are issues in my opinion
where the other side really has no good
arguments at all and you can hear them
out but they just they just and I we
talked about this week with the bathroom
thing I've heard out the other side and
they have no good at they really don't
have any good arguments I mean there are
positions that are just flat-out stupid
and wrong and and there's only so far
you can go and taking them seriously so
that's true but and you know that's not
the case with so many other issues and
so you seek out the other side let us
speak for themselves and and then you're
and now you're you know and now you're
formulating your own views and this is
pretty exciting it's very freeing
because now you're doing this honest
investigation and you're developing your
own perspective your own ideas and when
you consider the issue you know don't
worry about
whether the ideas and opinions you feel
forming are consistent with what people
have always told you or with what you
want to believe or anything else just
just let your brain and your mind do do
its own work and then as you engage with
all the sides you listen to the
arguments now you've kind of fueled your
brain and and you can really work it
over in your head so something I'll do
maybe this is because I'm schizophrenic
I don't know but I'll have arguments
with myself in my head I don't know if
this is I guess probably a lot of people
do this this is what I do I have
arguments with myself in my head all the
time
and if I have a viewpoint that I want to
defend that I believe that I think I'm
right about so I'm turning it over in my
head and I try to argue against myself
and I try to anticipate what in you know
an intelligent person might say in
response to that view and so now I'm
just like going back and forth in my own
mind and I think that's what critical
thinking consists of for everybody in
one form or another just one one good
tip is when you're arguing with yourself
in your mind
try not to especially there are people
around you don't don't verbalize
anything because you look crazy
one other thing to think about here I
think another good test another good
thing for a critical thinker to do is to
constantly be holding your views up
against your other views to see if
they're consistent I think this is one
thing we should always be doing is to
look for internal consistency within
your worldview and if you discover that
so if you have an opinion on an issue
and the arguments you present you
discover are not consistent with the
arguments you present on some other
topic where in other words you know you
present arguments on one topic but those
arguments if applied to your position
over here it would actually defeat your
own position and I think a lot of people
have a worldview full of stuff like that
it's just a tangled web where they've
just a Mis mishmash of of conflicting
contradicting ideas and that's a problem
because now you don't have a coherent
worldview and now also you know that you
must be wrong about some of
stuff because in order to be right about
this over here you got to be wrong about
that
and so that's another thing we have to
be analyzing and figuring out and in
trying to establish a worldview that's
coherent and we are you know we have
certain basic principles that we are
consistently applying across the board
to everything but your honor you're on
the great path already so
congratulations for that let's see this
is from Joseph says madam finally able
to say I was able to see the great
theocratic emperor in person I went to
the University of wisconsin-milwaukee
lecture and I loved every second of it
don't have a beard so I couldn't ask a
question in person that is a rule you
have to have you have to have a beard
ask a question so thank you for
following that rule I love that you
changed the topic and talked about
masculinity the speech reminds me of an
extended expanded aversion of the CS
Lewis quote we make men without chess
and expect of them virtue and enterprise
you mention the type of education system
you would send your kids to outside of
home I think what you described would be
the best but is it attainable you said
not government-run which also means not
government-funded if it's totally
private wouldn't it be hard for the
middle class and lower class to attend
these schools thanks for all you do yeah
well we live in a society right now
Joseph where is it is in many ways
structured around the current
educational system and dependent upon it
so any significant change to the system
would require necessitate a major change
to the way our society is structured and
there's no getting around that so but my
point is that we have to start by
realizing that the current system is
horribly fatally flawed and bad for
children and counterproductive and
harmful and all these things and we
start by realizing that and even if the
total solution the ultimate solution is
far in the future we can at least start
heading in that direction so when we're
taught when we're noticing that there's
something in society that is some major
thing in society that is fundamentally
flawed yeah that's going to mean that
fixing it is a real long-term solution
it's going to require a lot of sacrifice
and it's way in the future so
that is the case with with the education
is I think the ultimate goal for us
should be to get rid of the
government-funded state-sponsored
education system completely I think that
education should be a fundamentally
private endeavor I don't think the
government should be running it but is
that something that is a realistic goal
for the next five years no but I do
think it should be a goal
let's see
says hi Matt in your opinion is it
possible to establish a deep affinity or
friendship or a love relationship with
someone who thinks in the opposite way
on issues that are fundamental for such
a for us such as abortion or child abuse
in cases of gay / transgender propaganda
in schools well its owner you could
definitely have a friendship with
someone who disagrees with you
fundamentally on on anything I think
there's no reason why you can't be
friendly with and even friends with
someone who you disagree with on on
everything but if you're talking about a
romantic relationship potentially a
marriage with someone who's
diametrically opposed to you on the most
basic issues then if that I would be
very wary of and I would warn against
especially with something like abortion
and transgenderism among children and
child abuse because if you marry someone
who disagrees with you on those things
you've got two big problems one is that
your worldviews are so opposed so
separate that I think you're gonna have
trouble establishing that kind of
intimate and complete bond that you need
in a marriage because you just see the
world through completely different
lenses the other on a more practical
level and this is something that I think
people need to take in consideration on
a more practical level especially if
you're a man
pro-life you know against child abuse
against transitioning children which is
child abuse well if you marry a woman
who disagrees with you on that you have
no guarantee first of all that she won't
kill your child in the womb you have no
guarantee she won't what if you guys end
up conceiving a child when you didn't
mean to or intend to now you know that
you're married to someone who at least
considers it an option to go and kill
the child and I just that's not a
situation I would ever want to be in and
then also even after the child is born
you know what if the kid has a normal
phase when he's 3 or 4 years old and
starts going around saying that he's a
girl normal thing for there's a normal
phase for children of both genders to go
through and a normal confusion for them
to have especially if it's never been
explained to them what a boy and girl is
well you're married to someone who might
be inclined to encourage that
and fuel it and next thing you know you
know it's like the james-younger case
and you're married to someone who's
who's trying to change your son into a
girl so I would
that's this a bigger especially these
days and especially with the lack of
power legally that men have over these
situations so as a man you got to be
these are questions you got to be
talking about with a woman that you're
dating and and I really think you got to
be 100% on the same page at least with
that stuff before even considering
marriage so thanks for the question
thanks everybody for watching and
listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there